like what is reality do you ever think
about that
tell me more
are we
holographic in nature is this a
simulation
are we zeros and ones
are we you know what what where did we
come from are we aliens of some sort
like what is the nature of our reality
if you start thinking too much about
that stuff
aren't you just missing the the beauty
of this life and you're not present and
you're not just enjoying it or do you or
or can you do both i think that if no i
think knowing or or going towards
knowing
if i ever got to know which is probably
an unending
search until you die and i'm not ready
um
it would i would think there would be
a direction how to live your life right
like if you realize that this is just
like one of a thousand lives and it's
just some little increment and you are
just trying to learn the one lesson that
you left off within the last life to
come back and do the next version i was
thinking to myself i don't want to come
back and learn this lesson next time i
don't want to have to get to this point
to do this again i'm going to do it now
and um and so things like that it helps
me to figure out how to live my life
that makes sense i like that
have you figured out what that thing is
yet no of course not
it's just intuitive thoughts like as a
man are you tapped into your body like
that's one thing that i feel like men
are a little bit not quite as
in tune with but do you get are you in
do you feel like you're intuitive do you
feel like you like know where things sit
in your body can you feel
energy
um
probably not as well as as a woman does
i mean i i feel like i listen to my gut
really well that's good yeah that's it
yeah i mean i think i definitely do that
um you know and just being a
professional athlete like you're i'm
you're in tune to your body and your
mind and like like i think that just
comes kind of naturally so you know i
for myself like i go with whatever my
god like you know my mind i feel like i
overthink things a lot
so i'm like all right let's just settle
down like what's my what was my first
gut instinct where am i at
let's just do that don't don't come up
with a million different scenarios of
how this could go right or how it could
go wrong and play it all out what's your
gut say do that
and there must be some stories of both
those decisions the one that you went
with to get and the one that you didn't
like because you've proven this to
yourself somehow right
i mean when i whenever whenever i left
denver i was like all right like what do
what do i want to do no there was both
sides of it there was all this stuff i
was like all right my god like i can't
play here anymore like this is just it's
just i gotta go and so
and even even when i was done with
football then too i was like all right
like you know there's
other opportunities um you know the kids
were getting a little bit older
um you know you're getting pressure from
you know agents and and friends and
other people hey go do this go do that
um
and you know i just sat with myself and
i was like all right
you know my guts i'm done like i'm just
i'm tapped out here i'm tired like
you're just
hanging up you're done
so it wasn't hard it wasn't a hard
decision or it was it was it felt clear
at least
it felt clear enough you know but i mean
it was over a week or so so i mean i
mean it was you go back and forth back
and forth back and forth um and play it
all out and
but at the end of the day like
i think you just have to trust most
people have to trust yourself some
people can't trust themselves but i feel
like i can okay another thing that you
hit on that you said you love do you
like to talk to people about is health
and i'm super into it are you into
anything cool or crazy or different like
i have someone showing up when we're
done with these interviews to do my
first nad drip that's exactly what i was
gonna say nad that's exactly what i was
gonna say
you haven't done it i haven't done it
and the doctor i'm working with does it
like a front load so i do i'm doing five
out of ten days
okay so you're doing five days bro
i'm gonna do like i think i'm gonna do a
monday wednesday thursday friday monday
okay yeah i don't wanna you know i want
them to be able to get that i don't want
it to get all you know my bane and you
know yeah um
it's
you're you're gonna hate it oh great
you're gonna hate well maybe it just
depends like just have them go really
slow
yeah they say you can get nauseous oh
yeah oh great
so like
it feels like for me the first time like
i've done i've done uh i've done five
days in a row
um
and then three take a day off three days
uh i've done my latest was i just did uh
every monday
for six weeks
okay
and i'm about probably in another month
i'll probably go back and do another
like three or four day treatment um so i
played basket
i was playing basketball um with
kind of these older guys out of high
school down here
and like my left knee's always giving me
problems just
so always has just achy and like if i
jump on it too much like it just hurts
like help
and you know sleep anxiety like stress
like all those things
after you do nad for a couple days
you'll feel like you're 20 years old
you'll sleep like a baby
your stress will be down anxiety
um
it's
your appetite your energy
your recovery
like workouts recovery will be through
the roof
wow
this stuff's incredible
it's incredible my understanding was
it's kind of like i thought it was about
just detoxification then it was like no
it's kind of hormonal kind of balance
like it balances you out energy like
emotionally
then it's about you know um you know not
getting so much anxiety and stress like
and he you know doctor even said like
colors get brighter he's like honestly
the world kind of brightens up so it's
almost like a
cellular
boost it's just like almost like you
become like you go from human to
superhuman yeah well i mean nad is in
every cell in your body so it's in the
brain so it charges up every cell so as
you get older
i mean think about whenever you're a kid
like you could you could run around for
hours on end and like
like my kids don't stop
so you know you just boost up all those
cells again and it's it's
it's incredible stuff so have you tried
anything else like i think there's
curcumin there's like all kinds of other
things have you tried any other drips uh
no i mean i've done all like the big
chips but like
nad one is
i don't know how you could beat it
honestly i did a podcast with um
van carcillo hockey player for uh
blackhawks
and he's um
he's microdose and mushroom making a
company out of that
and i haven't really yeah and then my
doctor here who does the nad
um
he was saying that some of his
you know elite patients that are out
there killing it microdose lsd which is
scarier to me than mushrooms
yeah i mean well that's a synthetic yeah
exactly so it's a little a little bit
different when it's a synthetic but
the world of medicine is changing
rapidly but you know lsd i think lsd was
developed as a like a truth serum drug
way back in like the 60s or something
like that yeah i think they're using it
to yeah like you said like they capture
people and they just give them lsd isn't
that like mdma is that kind of all the
same stuff
mdm
no it's a little different that's molly
i think that just makes you happy that's
ecstasy i've never had that but
i'm sure it's great you're probably not
going to go ahead and divulge all of the
things that you've tried and i don't
blame you i honestly have never had
ecstasy you're retired now you can try
whatever you want i mean i think like
you said the world of world of medicine
and health and drugs is rapidly changing
and i think uh we're learning a lot more
than we ever have before well what's
next what's next on the try it list for
you other than micro dosing psilocybin
yeah i think it's i think that's what's
up next nad and that do more of that
maybe you should just go for the hero's
dose of psilocybin first
he we were talking about that
and he was like because i mean they're
walking they're walking people through
this like they'll set up a room
setting
gets you all geared up and stuff and
he's like listen he goes
the first couple hours might be the
worst experience of your life
and i'm like really he's like well you
have to go into it with a purpose you
got to have you know this is what i want
to accomplish and he said like the first
hour so he said it could be could be
absolute hell
he goes but then you get you get out of
it
and he goes you know you you mentally
you'll have a breakthrough and you know
you'll see things completely different
but that's what he's talking about is
like walking you through it like
creating the room creating the space
you know giving you giving you a safe
space so that you can let go right like
i said if you want to get into that you
know if you want to get hypnotized you
got to be able to let go like you got to
feel safe you got to be open to it do
you still work out a bunch i'm not as
much as i used to no you know more just
kind of stretching keeping things
together like
gaining gaining muscle is not my goal
anymore by any means speaking of knees
have you tried walking backwards in that
whole new craze
you should definitely look that up gabby
reese you know uh the volleyball player
her and laird they're super into fitness
and health and all things and um she
took me to the beach and we went uh we
went walking backwards for a couple of
miles but it's supposed to be incredible
for your knees well it makes sense
because you're going in one direction
your entire life yeah you're just you
know you're just wearing those muscles
out so
it makes it makes makes a lot of sense
[Music]